we are asked what is the critical value
t star t asterix for constructing a 98
confidence interval for mean from a
sample size of n is equal to 15
observations so just as a reminder of
what's going on here you have some
population there's a parameter here
let's say it's the population mean we do
not know what this is so we take a
sample here we're going to take a sample
of 15. so n is equal to 15 and from that
sample we can calculate a sample mean
but we also want to construct a 98
confidence interval about that sample
mean so we're going to go take that
sample mean and we're going to go plus
or minus some margin of error now in
other videos we have talked about that
we want to use the t distribution here
because we don't want to underestimate
the margin of error so it's going to be
t star
times the sample standard deviation
divided by the square root of our sample
size which in this case was going to be
15 so square root of n but what they're
asking us is well what is the
appropriate critical value what is the t
star that we should use in this
situation and so we're about to look at
a i guess we call it a t table instead
of a z table but the key thing to
realize is there's one extra variable to
take into consideration when we're
looking up the appropriate critical
value on a t table and that's this
notion of degree of freedom sometimes
it's abbreviated df and i'm not going to
go in depth on degrees of freedom it's
actually a pretty deep concept
but it's this idea that you actually
have a different t distribution
depending on the different sample sizes
depending on the degrees of freedom and
your degree of freedom is going to be
your sample size minus 1. so in this
situation our degree of freedom is going
to be 15 minus 1. so in this situation
our degree of freedom is going to be
equal to 14. and this is the first time
that we have seen this we talked a
little bit about degrees of freedom when
we first talked about sample standard
deviations and how to have an unbiased
estimate for the population standard
deviation and in future videos we'll go
into more advanced conversations about
degrees of freedom but for the purposes
of this example you need to know that
when you're looking at the t
distribution for a given degree of
freedom your degree of freedom is based
on the sample size and it's going to be
your sample size minus 1 when we're
thinking about a confidence interval for
your mean so now let's look at the t
table
so we want a 98
confidence interval
and we want a degree and we want a
degree of freedom of 14.
so let's get our t table out
and i actually copy and pasted this
bottom part moved it up so you can see
the whole thing here and what's useful
about this t table is they actually give
our confidence levels right over here so
if you want a confidence level of 98
you're going to look at this column
right over here another way of thinking
about a confidence level of 98 percent
if you have a confidence level of
that means you're leaving one percent
unfilled in
at either end of the tail and so if
you're looking at your t distribution
everything up to and including that top
one percent you would look for a tail
probability of zero 0.01
which is you can't see it right over
there let me do it in a slightly
brighter color which would be that tail
probability to the right but either way
we're in this column right over here we
have a confidence level of 98 percent
and remember our degrees of freedom our
degree of freedom here is we have 14
degrees of freedom and so we'll look at
this row right over here
and so there you have it this is our
critical t value 2.6
so let's just go back over here
and so there you have it we have 2.624
is our answer